we got this one from CW Atlanta security
barricades placed around Fulton County
Courthouse in Atlanta they are slow
rolling this one and we know what's
about to happen Fulton County D.A says
her team's work is accomplished setting
stage for Trump indictment announcement
as many as 18 people could be charged in
connection with attempts to overturn the
2020 election results I am mad at the
Democrats I'm not mad
at the Republicans yep the Republicans
in all of these different states and all
these different places do nothing they
don't use their power even when we do
have even when the right does have power
they don't use it they refuse to use it
because they don't want to be seen as
you know these right-wing fascist
dictators but the left they don't I
don't believe I don't know I believe
that I think that the Republicans who
are claiming they don't want to be
tyrannical are actually just in on it oh
yeah well it's a uniparty through and
through you know you have a select few
people you know congressmen
Representatives that maybe not be a part
of it they were not at the same time
yeah there's always going to be conflict
in the funeral party is still strong and
it's going to stay strong it's just a
matter of breaking that up why do you do
that where are we at with impeaching Joe
Biden over his obvious and discernible
Shady business dealings with his son
where where are we at there uh Kevin
McCarthy said we are now going to begin
the process of beginning an inquiry into
impeachment yep
so it'll never happen so now now we're
at the point where we decided to start
the process of asking the question does
this rise to the level of impeachment
which we already know it clearly does
but it's just a pony show that's really
it all it is is it's just four shows to
give people false hope you understand
they're fighting back oh yeah I mean he
could have been I think he could have
been impeached within his first month in
office I mean with all the evidence even
there was enough evidence with Hunter
Biden yeah if you want to make an
argument that those were pre-bidden
presidency then okay then Afghanistan
outright I mean that was such a disaster
an utter failure it warrants removal in
my opinion all the stuff that's coming
out about barisma and Ukraine and stuff
the the that's plenty of reason to
impeach there's that there's sufficient
evidence yeah the just the uh the
testimony from uh what's his name last
night or whatever the the guest on the
show last night no no the uh The
Whistleblower yeah The Whistleblower um
I mean Joe Biden was listening to all
the conversations Joe Biden would call
all of Hunter Biden's uh
just to be like hey I'm Joe Biden he's
actually like he can actually get me to
to you know help out if he needs or if
he needs help so you should probably do
what he says that's exactly what it was
it was it's as it's clear corruption and
I I don't know like I said like I said
last night I don't have a whole lot of
Hope in any kind of
you know impeachment or any kind of
actual Republicans don't do anything
yeah even at the state level what we're
looking at with the Fulton County D.A
this is this is local politics going
after Trump trying to stop him from
being able to run they don't want an
election the Democrats are doing this
because they know they lose
they will lose in if if everything is
done standard fair I wonder if they
would like lose like in a landslide
because like this the majority of people
are like really over the well once you
once you touch people's money it's over
once you touch people's money I think
that's the biggest indicator I have
left-wing people that I talk to all the
time that are suffering financially
that's the biggest hit I think that you
can do on somebody is once you mess with
somebody's Pockets they're going to
notice
I mean yeah
I mean there's there's sufficient reason
for the for the American people to not
like Joe Biden there is ample reason I
don't think that that he's a popular
president I don't think you need to
convince people that Joe Biden has done
you know a bad job I I don't think
that's the argument that the I think uh
that anyone really needs to make I think
people need to read you know more
history if you look at countries that
fall into Revolution or Civil War
because what's happening now with the
indictment of Donald Trump the third
technically what about the third
indictment
potentially moving to the fourth this is
worse than what happened in some of the
you know greater Revolutions in Civil
Wars throughout history up to a certain
point obviously so you know I was
reading about the uh the Revolutions in
Russia star Nicholas and things like
that Spanish Civil War Weimar Germany
and there were things that happened that
were considered to be major catalysts of
Revolution Civil War that were not on
par with one leader weaponizing
government against his rival political
faction to this degree some of these
major political moments were like a
referendum was held and power was
transferred from the executive branch to
the you know to Parliament and it's like
that was considered a great Revolution
and things like that it was like a
tremendous moment happened when the
monarchy transferred certain executive
powers to parlor for parliamentary
decisions and they call that the great
upheaval or something like that this is
Joe Biden is trying to physically remove
his his principal rival because he's
losing in the polls
well I don't know about because he's
losing in the polls I think he would do
that even if he was winning the polls
well what I mean is like yeah we can we
can we can look at the polls and see
Biden's losing yeah and it would seem
that the only reason to really go for
Trump in this way is because they know
they can't win like like I said earlier
today I I think that that this is bigger
than Trump I think that this is about
making a statement about people that are
Outsiders not even really attempting to
get into the the office and and and kind
of bust your way into the Inner Circle
and try to make changes and make demands
I really think that the the the
established bureaucracy really hates
Trump because he would have made
significant changes if he if they
allowed him to we gotta stay him I want
to read Trump's statement he is he
responded to the indictment he says this
is nothing more than the latest corrupt
chapter in the continued pathetic
attempt by the Biden crime family and
their weaponized Department of Justice
to interfere in the 2024 presidential
election in which president Trump is the
Undisputed FrontRunner and leading by
substantial margins but why did they
wait two and a half years to bring these
fake charges right in the middle of
President Trump's winning campaign for
2024.
why was it was it announced the day
after the big crooked Joe Biden scandal
broke out from the halls of Congress the
answer is election interference the
lawlessness of these persecutions of
President Trump and his supporters is
reminiscent of Nazi Germany in the 1930s
the former Soviet Union and the
authoritarian dictatorial regimes and
other authoritarian dictatorial regimes
president Trump has always filed the law
on the Constitution with advice from
many highly accomplished attorneys these
Un-American witch hunts will fail and
president Trump will be re-elected to
the White House so we can save our
country from the abuse incompetence and
Corruption that is running through the
veins of our country at levels never
seen before three years ago we had
strong borders energy Independence no
inflation and a great economy today we
are a nation in Decline president Trump
will not be deterred by disgraceful and
unprecedented political targeting
well I don't think I think we were still
in Decline we were just in a bubble uh
the Federal Reserve screwed us 2007 was
on the obvious example of how we're in
Decline we've been in Decline since we
went on fiat currency so I can't stand
when Trump takes credit for a booming
economy when it was a bubble but that
part other than that part he's this
sounds about right you do not per
politically persecute your opponents in
the middle of an election season the day
after your son gets shown for being
corrupt I mean this is what they claimed
Trump was doing they claimed Trump was
trying to dig up dirt on Joe Biden and
that was impeachable offense Joe Biden
is literally indicting the front runner
and they're like it's a good thing these
are evil people they know what they're
doing they know they are evil yeah I
agree with the typical blame others of
what you're guilty of that's really what
we're seeing here and they're just going
to continue to do so and they're and the
Republicans do nothing they're guarding
that inner circle of the unit party like
Hillary's still pissed that Trump said
you'd be in jail on the stage humiliated
her like she's not gonna let that go
she's going to watch until her last day
on Earth she's going to be wanting to
make that guy's life miserable and she
has a lot of connections and a lot of
power in the US government obviously
um
and that's I that that's why I get to
the point where I'm like nothing I can
do can help this system nothing I can do
politically can help if I I don't even
want Trump to get elected but if I want
to do nothing I can do could help him
get elected nothing all I can do is make
hit records and maybe people will cry in
their sleep and realize that life's not
so bad and fighting each other helping
someone get elected is quite simple if
you go to someone and say register to
vote and vote for Trump you are helping
Trump get elected
the reason I said no I feel like nothing
I can do is because I feel like if I got
100 million of a million people
registered it would just it doesn't
matter because I don't I can't read the
vote you got to prove to me that that
voting system is legit if you're gonna
do that in secret then I don't have any
evidence that you're doing it right it's
like secret Bella has always been the
thing in the U.S like well we don't we
don't get to see
who voted for who yeah but the idea that
we take all the ballots send them to a
private company that goes behind a black
curtain and comes out and says trust us
this guy won yep yeah BS
that that that's we can't we can't work
that way and so now we're seeing there's
been there's been like Court rulings
overturning these these attempts to stop
Universal mail and voting and things
like this
if it if it comes down to ease of access
for random people to vote Democrats are
for it if it comes down to security
Republicans are for it
I'm not I'm neither I just want like
secure I mean secure the right one sorry
to interrupt you what were you about to
say I I just want transparency in my
election process so that's security yeah
you want it that's what the right
response and that's what this whole
thing has been about is we want fair and
free elections we want transparent
elections you have to but then I could
see like the if the mob truly voted in a
psychopath you want like someone behind
this curtain being like uh Psychopaths
can't get in or we'll lose everything
okay let's no well I mean if you look at
like if you're actually I'm talking
about a psychopath right like majority
of CEOs or Psychopaths I'd say a good
majority of our presidents have been
Psychopaths because you need that extra
Edge I mean I I say God you know gifted
a psychopath for a reason granted not a
lot of them are great but we need them
in society they're a natural occurring
let me let me read this tweet from uh
Jack the sobeck he said the Trump case
has been assigned to U.S District Judge
Tanya s chutcon according to the court
DACA chitcon and Obama appointee is the
only federal judge in D.C who has
sentenced j6 defendants to send
sentences longer than the government had
requested
very obvious where this is going yep
y'all are in a civil war and people like
to ignore it but just read about the U.S
Civil War the Spanish Civil War the the
the Russian revolutions there was more
than one read about the French
Revolution more than one and it's
interesting how they kind of like 75
years to figure out how to like have a
proper government that's in foreign
first they had a revolution and then
Napoleon became emperor yeah it's like
huh and another Revolution they had a
revolution that went wrong and then
wrote they start killing people that was
the big problem that was back before
Napoleon and then after Robespierre was
killed there was some turmoil then
Napoleon was worried about Russia he was
like I'll take it and the Bolsheviks
right about Russia is particularly
interesting failed leadership people
were unhappy is a simple way to put it
and so you take a look at what's going
on now and this reaches the level of
historical
historical Revolution Civil War or
collection and it makes sense on the
timeline of History because all the
cultures of Earth are blending now and
causing mass chaos in the United States
particularly is like the is the front
runner so it makes sense that we'd be
facing revolutionary pressure or or
civil unrest or Civil War like pressure
it makes total sense now we just got to
see how do we fortify against it because
if it's obvious that it's happening it
makes sense that it would be happening
then there's got to be an antidote but
how do you fortify against something
when you don't control the institutions
we don't control any sort of power
whatsoever regarding the institutions
and the institutions are going to be
where the majority of the ideological uh
basically brainwashing is carried out I
guess you build your own institutions
it's challenging when you're up against
a monopoly um like mines is like a
social network that's free software uh
has no political leanings
um you know daily wire is a good example
of something that appeared out of uh or
like a angel Studios you know that's
kind of a new institution that can make
whatever movie that want and it'll get
put in movie theaters around the world
regardless of the gatekeeps
that's one way to do it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time